hace unos momentos el telescopio
espacial james webb completó su
encendido y ha llegado a su punto final
de destino
misión es el ojo de la humanidad en la
inmensidad del espacio el telescopio
james webb ya está en su destino final
orbitando a 1,5 millones de kilómetros
de la tierra ahora deberá esperar a que
sus espejos se alineen y sus detectores
infrarrojos se enfrían las observaciones
empezarán en junio cuando se abrirá la
exploración de nuevas partes del
universo
te estaremos observando cosas en el
universo que van desde objetos dentro de
nuestro propio sistema solar toda la
búsqueda de las primeras galaxias
nacidas después del big bang y todo en
el espacio-tiempo entremedio va a ser
increíble
con un presupuesto de más de 10 mil
millones de dólares
el telescopio intentará obtener
informaciones inéditas del cosmos como
la luz de las primeras estrellas y
galaxias de apenas unos 100 millones de
años después del big bang también
observará agujeros negros buscará
planetas extraños y tratará de encontrar
agua en otros mundos
una forma de buscar las respuestas a las
preguntas fundamentales de la humanidad
en la misión web de comprender esos
planetas va realmente el núcleo del ser
humano y a preguntas fundamentales cómo
estamos solos de dónde venimos a dónde
vamos el universo es enorme
james webb lleva el nombre del director
de la nasa durante los años 60 cuando el
ser humano llegó a la luna el telescopio
partió el 25 de diciembre desde la
guayana francesa y un mes después ya
está listo para llevar otra vez más a la
ciencia a una nueva era